Ayal Yogev, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
Good, good.
Thank you for having me.
Of course.
So, incredible journey
that I can't wait to dive into,
whether it's from starting a company
which you're doing now,
to being a VP product at a startup.
But before that, being in a corporate
like Cisco and that whole transition.
But even before that,
drawing on your, what you say,
your first entrepreneurial experience,
so commanding one of the most prestigious
computer courses
in the Israeli Defense Forces,
which I think
it's an incredible take to look at it
from an entrepreneurial perspective.
So, I can't wait to hear about that.
But before everything
Ayal, we have to talk
a little bit about Survivor.
Because I'm a huge huge fan.
It's been a dream
since I'm like six years old
to be on Survivor.
Why do you love the show?
I love the game.
It's such a smart and fun game.
And basically, you throw
a bunch of people onto an island,
I guess, it's not about these competitions
that they do, it's about the social game
and how you get people to follow you.
And eventually, you're essentially
you vote them out,
you do all the things
and eventually [--] them
to vote for you
and how you handle the social,
it's just phenomenal.
I think it's exactly,
it's such an incredible game.
Because like you're saying,
a lot of people are enjoying
the challenges and the drama,
it's not about that.
It's about this whole idea of
how do you go through a journey
and reaching the finals is not enough
because then you have to have the jury.
People that you blindsided
and you voted out coming in.
And I don't want to give any spoilers
to people, but I'll give a small one.
There is a player on the American series
who I believe got to second place
twice or three times
over the 40 seasons.
So, they brought this player back
because he was so entertaining
and he's very very intelligent.
He runs, I believe,
a fuel company in the US.
But he only managed to get second place
exactly for that reason.
Because he missed out on that
other whole aspect of the game.
And so, we have much more to talk about.
I'm actually now watching
the 37th season and I'm loving it,
but we'll have to catch up
a little bit later about that.
Ayal, take me back to your journey.
Who are you
way before you started
a cybersecurity company
here in the United States?
Sure. So I guess very, very quickly,
I started my journey
in the Israeli intelligence forces.
And basically I joined
when I was in unit 8200,
but I cannot say that in the podcast.
And essentially I've been there
for about six years.
And I guess my last,
the last thing I did there
was running a course,
as you said, it was one of the,
it's the course that I probably
wouldn't have got into
as a teen as an 18 year old.
But I was so lucky enough
to be part of essentially, starting there
I was very involved since the first one
and got to be the commander
of the first one.
Oh wow, I didn't know that. Wow.
Yeah. I was a teacher
in the first and second one,
and then I was commanding the fifth one.
So, again, it was an amazing experience.
And what's very unique
about this specific,
I don't think I'm gonna dive deeper
into that,
but what's unique is that
it basically involves
a lot of different units
within the Israeli intelligence community.
Which is extremely unique
for any course, which again poses
a bunch of unique challenges
that you don't see in other courses
in terms of,
and again, I can't go in depth
but there's so much
of the politics behind it.
Everybody wants to get
the best people to come in,
but they don't actually want
to give the resources
because there's this other unit
needs to give the resources.
Right. Now, Ayal, just for context,
because a lot of people
that are watching this
from outside of Israel may not realize,
but this specific course in general,
the Army does a really great job
at creating this filter.
They're starting out
that they're getting anybody
who might be remotely interested
in computer science
going through a series of tests
just as comprehensive, if not,
more than the college applications
to Stanford, MIT or Harvard.
It's really remarkable
the way that they're doing it.
At the end, you reach a cohort
of just a few dozen people
out of thousands.
And it's like this childhood dream.
If before, people dreamt of being pilots
and dreamt of being
in the elite combat units,
now, a lot of people are dreaming about
getting to the course, specific one
that you helped initiate
and that you commanded
its fifth iteration.
And so, that's also why people
that are in the course,
they're so sought after
and to all the other units,
because these are
some of the most brilliant minds.
Talk to me a little bit about being 23,
getting thrown into this responsibility
of leading this course.
And you're saying that this is
your first entrepreneurial journey, right?
Yes, exactly.
Part of this was the fact
that you have to,
you're getting 23 years old,
you're not extremely senior
in terms of your rank,
but then you have to deal with
all these extremely senior people.
The head of the steering committee
for the course
is the second in command in unit 8200.
And you have to deal with
all these people
that are basically
10 levels higher than you are
from all these different units.
And again, and you need to make sure that,
and one thing is they give you this
you can do whatever you want, right?
You can do, you can pretty much,
obviously on the technical side,
none of these people
really have any idea
what you're doing.
You know way better than they are.
But also just in terms of leadership
you are thrown in this remote location
that's not within one of the bases.
And you can pretty much,
you have all this freedom
to get people ready
and do what you need to do
to get them ready for their service.
But the other thing is the resources.
It's getting the resources that you need,
getting everything, pulling together
the things that you need
from all these different units.
It was an amazing experience
that it taught me a lot about
how to handle large organizations;
how to handle politics;
how to work with people who are not,
obviously, they'll report to you,
but also they are
much more senior than you.
It was, and again, an amazing experience.
I probably think some of the gray hair
that I have now,
it's probably due to that experience,
but it was amazing.
And the other one
even more amazing thing is that
I actually I met my wife.
She was actually running
the recruitment process for this course,
and that's how we met.
Oh, that's just beautiful.
That's wonderful.
But the course itself,
it's not just another programming course.
There's a lot of courses out there.
It's not like taking a class at MIT
and it's not like going
to a summer program to learn how to code.
This is a very intensive period,
where you,
as the commander over the course,
don't just have
the professional responsibility
for the people going through it,
but you're really responsible
for their livelihoods
over the course of a few months.
They're relocated to another area
and they look at you
as the commander in charge.
And like you're mentioning, at 23,
you're given responsibility
that a lot of people
that are ten ranks above you,
that's the responsibility
that they've been working for
for a long time.
So, definitely, I totally appreciate
what you're doing there.
And I helped teach quite a bit
in different courses,
not the specific one,
but it's a remarkable experience.
Ayal, you transition to the United States,
you do an MBA at Berkeley,
you're at Cisco,
and you're transitioning from there
towards another startup.
Talk to me a little bit
about that transition,
or if you even want to go before
to another startup you worked at
which was acquired by Cisco.
Sure. So, basically,
since after I left the military,
I went to work for a bunch of start ups.
And I was always, you have to,
and again, now a start up
when at Cisco,
you interview a lot of people.
And you see that some people
are more of startup people
and some people
love the bigger companies.
And some people like both.
And there's no right and wrong there.
It's your personality,
what you like doing.
And one of the things
I always ask people is
that want to join us is,
"Why startup?"
And part of it is just making sure
that they understand what that is,
and part of it to make sure
it's a good fit.
And I, again,
maybe it was that experience.
Maybe it was just [--].
I knew that startups was probably
the right thing for me.
I end up working for a few startups.
Very early in my career
I worked for a startup
that got acquired by IBM.
And that even reinforced
my thinking that a big company
is probably not for me.
Even though, again,
I think IBM was very, again,
there's a lot of great things to say
about IBM, but the culture
wasn't a great fit for me at the time.
And then I decided to come here to the US
and basically get my MBA at Berkeley.
And that was to me,
a way to move to the Bay Area
where everything happens.
It was a really really great way
to come in.
Obviously, somebody that grew up
in Israel and worked in Israeli,
it was tech companies
that most of the business in the US.
But I didn't really have
a strong US network.
And this was just a great way
to come to the Bay Area,
build a network here.
That was an amazing,
amazing experience.
And after doing that,
I worked at a couple of startups
here in the US.
The second one I worked for
was a company called OpenDNS,
and about a year in
we got acquired by Cisco.
And again, I remember getting the email
from the CEO saying Cisco is acquiring us.
It was I think why I woke up
very early that morning
and [--], the email in my inbox
and I remember thinking,
it's going to be the IBM experience
all over again.
But it ended up being amazing.
Cisco is very very good
at acquiring companies.
I think it's one of the companies
that acquired the most companies
went through the most M&A ever,
and it was just a phenomenal experience.
And it got me the view
of what it's like to work
in this very very large organization.
And again, I can talk a lot
about how well the merged
that's  into the organization
and how our CEO ended up becoming
the head of SVP and GM
for security at Cisco.
What is one thing that you experience
which was very positive
in the mergers and acquisitions?
because a lot of the people
that I talked to on the show,
they've gone through these
different mergers and acquisitions,
it sounds like the majority of them
aren't as successful
as people hope them to be, right?
And obviously, it's extremely difficult
and complicated process, not just
technologically and professionally,
but also in terms of the culture.
Because you're going from a small startup,
even a hundred people is tiny
compared to thousands of people
at a large organization
when all of a sudden
you have a new identity.
So, what was one thing that
you found really helpful
in your transition?
The one thing I think
Cisco did very very well,
and I think IBM
that's where they missed,
Cisco basically gave us the autonomy
and they didn't come in and told us,
"This is what you need to do."
"You need to change everything
to be Cisco."
And again, eventually it happened
over a number of years.
But they came in
and nothing changed in the beginning.
We still had our
the same reporting structure,
we still had the autonomy that we had.
There were a lot of things,
I'm sure very difficult for Cisco
to agree to
because they were very different
than how they do things.
I'm sorry.
But they didn't really change any of that.
They allowed us to continue
doing everything as we did.
And to some extent
that their approach was,
"You guys have built something
very very successful."
"You guys are doing something amazing."
"We want to come in and learn from you."
And they changed a lot of their,
what I did there was I was running
the product management organization
for Umbrella, which was
the leading product that we had.
And they were basically saying,
"We want to learn from you."
"How do you guide from product?"
And I ended up getting a bunch
of other product groups
reporting into me from Cisco.
This I-can't-say group
ended up reporting into my organization.
They basically said,
"You guys know how to do this?"
"Because you are
a very very successful company."
Which, again, was I think,
was a very very smart way
of doing things.
Right.
So then, you're transitioning from Cisco.
And I'd love to make sure
we have enough time to also talk about
the current startup that you're running.
Because now you've transitioned after
being at a few startups,
being at a few corporate,
being a commander in the IDF,
you're now starting your own company.
So, tell me a little bit about
Anjuna Security
and some of the insights
that you've gained
throughout the process
of starting this company.
Sure. So, I guess due to a lot
of what I did throughout my career
was getting ready for this.
I always knew I wanted to start
my own company.
And a lot of what I did
was geared to that.
Even in my MBA,
I did my internship at a VC firm
just to see the other side of the table
looks like and learn from that.
So, after Cisco,
I went to a VP Product
series A startup at the time,
series B startup now.
I have to see what it's like to be
an executive at a startup
and get that experience as well.
Very cool.
And then my time there
was cut short
because a friend of mine that I knew
from the Israeli intelligence days,
he was actually a teacher at the course
I was a commander of,
he reached out to me
and he just finished his PhD at Stanford
working with Professor Dan Boneh
that you might know.
Of course.
So, he basically researched this,
it's funny, it was this huge huge
security problem that we both knew about
in the Israeli military intelligence
and to say it in one sentence is that,
you can't secure data
and use it at the same time.
Every time data is being used,
it's essentially not,
it's not being secured
because it has to be
in the clearing memory.
And I ran into that problem
again and again throughout
going in the private sector
as well as at Cisco,
in a lot of places
I ran into how big that problem was.
And he actually found a solution
for that problem during his PhD
with Dan Boneh.
So, we ended up joining forces
and starting a company
to actually solve this problem.
Wow. So, you became a co-founder
of this company, right?
And you joined.
So, what's actually happening now?
Where is the company in the life cycle
of a traditional startup?
So, this was about
two and a half years ago.
The first thing we did
was start talking to
as many potential customers
as it's possible to somewhat understand
if we got the right problem.
Once we had enough information,
we basically built a deck
and started pitching this to investors.
We ended up getting both a seed round.
So we raised our dollar seed
as well as got into Y Combinator.
Amazing.
And when we did that at the time
it was the same week that we got
the term sheet for the investment
and the call from YC.
It was a good week.
After a very difficult couple of months
it was a very good week.
And yes, since then, we grew the company.
We raised a significant series A.
And we're now basically
a company of 20 people.
Wow. That's incredible.
Tell me a little bit about Y Combinator,
because that's something
that almost every startup seize
as the glory of programs to go through
to accelerate your growth.
What was that experience like
going through it?
Yeah. YC is amazing.
It's basically a startup school.
It's obviously it helped
the company a lot,
but what YC is very very good at
is making sure you know what to focus on.
That you focus on the right things
and that you only focus
on the right things.
And they're just amazing
at making you do that.
So, it's obviously a great experience
for the company.
But it's also an amazing school
for me as an entrepreneur.
Just to doing it is very very different
than seeing it from the sidelines.
And again, I've seen it from the,
I was part of it as an exec,
I was part of it as an employee,
I was looking at it from the outside,
I was doing the internship at a VC,
but nothing helps you get actually ready
and really understanding
what you're going to go through
as an entrepreneur.
And the one thing that does the best
is YC are really doing
a really really great job.
And the last thing that YC is doing is,
and I think you probably heard this a lot,
this is not becoming a cliche,
but being an entrepreneur
is an extremely lonely job.
There's really no one
that you can talk to.
The again, the investors
you have a great relationship
you can talk to about a lot of things,
but again, you need to be very thoughtful
about what you tell them
and how you tell them things.
If you very existential,
you don't really share things like that.
And the same with your employees, right?
You want to shield them
with a lot of these ups and downs
that you might be experiencing.
And what's nice about what YC
is that you get this cohort
of other founders,
that you can share all these things with
that is extremely extremely helpful.
Right. 100%.
So, what was probably
the most helpful event within YC?
Was it the network
that you were creating there?
Was it the goal setting?
I mean, I'm guessing
that it was primarily the founding team
that took part of it, right?
Not necessarily
the rest of the employees as actively.
No. It was just me and my co-founder.
And we started YC extremely early
in the company's journey, again,
as we were getting the term sheet
for the seed,
we got into YC the same week.
And YC is essentially
only for the founders.
And it was me and my co-founder
that went through this.
In terms of what we got from it,
one is, the YC network is phenomenal.
If you're part of the YC network
you can pretty much,
it's like we email the founders of Airbnb
and got a response back within minutes.
It's just this amazing network
of founders.
It is just phenomenal.
And also, YC continues, and again
they helped us understand
what we need to focus on,
make sure we're focused on it.
You work with two partners
throughout the program
and they help you reach the milestones
that you need to reach.
But also they continue to help you
after you come out of YC.
And you're still part of the network.
You can still do office hours.
You can still talk to people
whenever you want.
Plus they have these
growth programs as well.
They have something called
the series A program
that we actually didn't go through.
We actually are lucky
to be [--] for our series A.
But they do help companies
in raising their series A
and getting ready to raise their series A.
They also have a growth program
that help companies
once they reach about 50 people
growing the company since then.
So, YC keeps helping you
throughout the lifecycle of the company.
And obviously they've seen probably
more startups than anyone else.
So they can do a really good job
at helping you there.
And that's just phenomenal.
Ayal, best of luck with the startup.
It sounds incredible.
And I just love this journey
that you went on.
And you really got to taste
so many different parts
of the tech ecosystem.
And the fact that you're saying that
a lot of these experiences
were geared towards preparing you
for this incredible journey
that you're on now,
I think that's just really awesome way
of looking at it.
And the way that you are talking
about your experience
as the commander of that course
in the IDF,
I think it totally resonates.
And I think it's part of the magic
of startup nation, part of the magic
that also Eric Schmidt talks about a lot.
And the book, obviously,
Startup Nation talks about
that it's this innovation
through necessity.
And when you think about commanding
a course in the IDF,
you don't necessarily think about,
you think about
the professional side of it
and the mentorship,
but you're presenting
this whole other side of
you had to innovate your network,
to innovate politics in order to make sure
that this works.
Ayal, before we leave,
I want to thank you
for being so generous of your time.
What are three words
that you would use to describe yourself?
Sure. So, well, you gave me a minute
before we started to think, so yeah.
I think that the three words
I would use are, one is passionate.
Number two is curious.
And I really believe in the
student always mentality.
I think you can always get better.
You can always learn more.
And I love learning new things.
And the last one is empathetic.
Why is that?
Explain that a little bit more.
I think one of the best things,
especially CEO
regardless if he is a manager,
but definitely as an entrepreneur,
the one important thing you build
is not actually the product,
it's the company.
And a huge piece of building a company
is the culture that you build.
And one of the things
I'm focusing on the most
is how do I build the right culture.
How do I build a culture
that I would want to be a part of.
And again, working for a lot of startups
I've seen better cultures
and worst cultures.
And it got me thinking a lot about
what culture I want to build.
And I want to have a place
where people enjoy being a part of it.
And to me it's all about, I think,
I actually have a little story,
which I think is he best way
to think about this.
I was lucky to meet Eric Yuan,
the founder of Zoom
on a couple of occasions
and small group settings.
And he talks about the culture
that he's building.
And he see all these companies
with the company values,
the seven things they put on the wall
and it's like super,
I think nobody nobody reads it,
nobody remembers it.
He said, and we adopted it
that are in Anjuna as well,
he said the one company value
that they have, is care.
He said it's caring about the employees,
caring about the customers,
caring about your investors.
So, it's the one thing.
And every time I go back
decision to make,
I go back to that
and thinking about that.
And I think that's an extremely
important piece of building a company.
Wonderful.
Ayal, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
This was just that wonderful.
Best of luck.
Thank you.
Best of luck to you.
Bye bye.